this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised good afternoon and a very warm
welcome to a sunny beautiful afternoon
in South Africa as you can see there are
some big gray animals that's while
moving around in front of us my name is
Tristan and on camera I've got a Craig
this afternoon and it is very lovely to
have you all join us aboard the larger
Safari vehicle in the world and so we
hope that you're going to have a
wonderful afternoon with us as we
explore the wilderness and hope that you
will ask lots and lots of questions on
hashtag safari live now behind Craig is
a very curious elephant that's just
poking up behind him I don't think Craig
actually even noticed that there was an
Ellie right behind the car so there's a
nice big herd that has come from galago
pan and where they've been drinking and
they're slowly now just meandering
through the bush feeding and it's so
wonderful to have Ellie's back on the
property we had a rather dry patch when
it came to Ellie's over the past week
and it's so it's really really good to
have these guys back in the area and
moving about once again and my plan is
probably to spend quite some time with
these guys this afternoon I thoroughly
enjoy being in amongst elephants and so
it seems like the right and fitting
thing to do the interesting thing about
these dailies is that they are right at
camp and it's why we actually found them
we are no more than I would say 2 3 2 2
300 meters from the final control
building which is straight in that way
so there we go there's the final control
we had some of the guys walking around
there a little bit earlier you can see
the Ailey's are all about the place so
it's quite nice just goes to show how
lucky we are to live here in Juma
because we have animals that literally
walk around us and live around us all
the time it's it's a wonderful thing to
be in a place when you walk outside of
your work area and there is one of a
sudden a big grey elephant in front of
you it's absolutely great pleasant John
you say there is an elephant in the room
yes there is this is the one time where
it is not just a saying but rather a
reality now hopefully the elephants
don't actually go deeper into the
FC building because there's nice new
trees that have been planted there they
have put in a whole bunch of indigenous
trees that's given a few years will grow
into beautiful big lovely examples of
some of the more rare trees that we get
in this area so things like Cape ashes
and pod mahogany's which we don't see
too many of here and if the alias' smell
and stuff those are given that it is
winter they will absolutely destroy all
of those trees so as much as it's nice
to have them on the fringes let's hope
that they don't go in there because
otherwise all the hard work of some of
the guys recently is going to be undone
and there will be death and destruction
to many a young little tree right well
we're going to sit with our elephant
herd like I say we're going to watch
them as they destroy the sickle Bush
that is around us and while we do that
it sounds like Sydney's off to a
rollicking start of his own and wants to
say good afternoon good afternoon
everyone and welcome to the beginning of
my game Drive I am Sydney and I am not
traveling alone this afternoon I am with
David David is my camera operator and my
plan for this afternoon it wasn't that
difficult it was quite an easy plan it's
just that I've already executed my plan
it was looking for the cat's I've
already got Hassan as I'm talking to you
now but after this sighting I'll be
looking for some other general game so
for your questions and comments you can
follow us on Twitter hashtag Safari live
and you can also find us on YouTube chat
stream or sauna is very much relaxed at
the moment but when we got here he was
sleeping completely flat so but now I
can see he's up and running and hello
hello again to everyone so look at horse
I'm not trying to pick up the
information and getting updates this cat
was sleeping flat when we got here but
I'm cleared that just by the nick of
time the beginning of the game Drive
hosana is starting to
show of some activities look at that
moving showing that it's not sleeping
anymore we are so very lucky so by this
time of the day beautiful case such as
this ones they profess to just rest and
rest and they normally do what he is
doing now late in the afternoons look at
that pink nose so the wind is is too
much but the wind is coming towards was
on at this stage I'm sure husana can be
able to detect what is on the northern
side and what is on the western side
look at that I am NOT very sure in terms
of the whole statistics of lepers in
South Africa as the lepers are very much
shy to see them is not very easy we are
just very much luck here in Juma Game
Reserve other areas catch such as
Leopard are difficult to find
I used to work for the South African
national parks and I was based in
Moroccan national park which is not very
far away from Johannesburg and there for
me to see the cats it was very much
difficult and in some areas the owners
sometimes they think they are not there
anymore
these cats they can even extend
territories even cross to some of the
neighbouring areas we do have a lot of
leopards in South Africa at this stage
and hunting of lepers at this stage it
is not allowed look at that husana is
excited there's something fascinating oh
yes there's been some impalas I can see
them on that side
so husana is very much excited there's
some impalas I can see them going down
towards that side maybe that is what
excited Hosanna
Elya on so let me just see what was a
nice thinking but the tail is telling me
that hosanna is interested on something
so I normally consider 8 on the tail
miss anomalous the the bell is at the
moment Hosanna I couldn't manage to read
but it's not that very fall I think he
might be a little bit hungry at the
moment so but I will again check nicely
when he's moving towards the eastern
side they just they're now trying to
become a fledged behind the tree and I
don't want to spoil this hunt I will
just remain here where I am now and see
his intentions they is he moving
since like asana I gave up that way is
now he can see those impalas they're
right on the road going down that side I
didn't see them he's he's shown them I
saw them before me so now it's just very
relaxed by this side of the tree where
is some little bit of [ __ ] look at that
something surprised Hassan
he's not feeling safe as well you can
see predators are predators but they
also think about their own safety look
at that you can see the wind is blowing
now the wind is blowing towards where
those animals are I'm not too sure if
those animals can be able to detect its
presence from the sense of smell
so normally by this time of the day they
don't really pay for mounting activities
so while I'm here with our sauna I still
have got my other colleague James has
not yet introduced himself let's hear
from James now I am introducing myself
I'm standing here in the valley of the
Gresham remati on my way down south to
find handy it is checked
my name is James Henry and I'm here on
Sunday afternoon bushwalk more often not
in the last little while I have been on
both walk on Sunday which has been great
fun it has a nice sort of warm Sunday
afternoon feel about at the moment
Sebastian jambe the greatest French
Gabonese Air Force pilot in history is
on camera and of course there has not
forget in a well not new but certainly
first seen shirt today Herbert causa in
royal navy blue and think you can have
royal navy blue it's either royal or
navy but I'm not sure what that one is
anyway I'll plan today like I say is to
head down towards the sort of central
sections of Jummah central south and see
if we can't find some sign of Tandy and
her nine-month-old daughter salamba well
Simon is actually very close to here
you've just been with him and Sydney and
so we'll just quietly sort of sneak
around and then move down towards the
central parts quite a lot of bird
activity around here which is not
particularly usual for the wintertime
and I wanted to show you some arrow mark
babblers and some oxpeckers you can see
the babblers just hopping on the floor
there say button if you can see them
just in the undergrowth there birding on
foot
you'd think intuitively would be easier
than in a car but actually it isn't it
seems you easier from a vehicle so those
are the arrow mark babblers and if we
just look down here you can see the very
thickly wooded banks of this dry
riverbed there's a lovely little breeze
blowing now making that sort of dry hot
try warm
winter air and rustling of the leafless
trees Mario is very simple to work out a
wooden direction you do this when your
finger feels cold you stop that's where
the moon's coming from and you work out
the direction it's pretty simple here
Mario it's almost always interesting Lee
it's not South East today it's almost
always coming from the southeast now
today and usually it's coming from the
northwest so that it is quite strange
all you do is feel which way it's coming
from work out the direction and you go
for it to you it's no more complicated
than that really it can swirl slightly
and if it does start to swirl well then
I have me trusty ash bag in here which
is a sock and if you've seen the ash bag
before it was merely a sock filled with
ash and I already said there you can see
the air is blowing well actually
interestingly in a slightly easterly
direction ah it's all swirling all over
the place
love my no I'm afraid not haven't seen
any cheater for a while we were
expecting that mother and two Cubs to
come back this way they were certainly
heading this way about a week ago now
they were heading back this way but they
seemed to have turned and gone back
towards the west perhaps that has
something to do with the return of the
Inka Huma pride back here
Cheeta will generally try and avoid
being anywhere around the dominant
predators especially lions and there is
some set research from this area that
suggests their distribution is almost
entirely predictable from lion calls so
where there are Lions calling you will
not find cheetahs so perhaps the return
of the in Kahuna's to the north ear has
sent them away we're going to continue
down this magnificent little game path
in the middle of this dry riverbed a
game path made by elephants
well good luck James I hope that you
find Tandy and Columba I was going to
head off in that direction myself before
we bumped into these Ellie's so once
we're done with the Edie's a little bit
later we'll probably go and give James a
bit of a hand in that area and try and
see if we can find the new queen of
Juma's has been a while since I've spent
a long time with her so I would really
like to go and have a nice afternoon
with tan daeun and hopefully it'll clear
lumber as well would be very very good
and when I Ellie's are still doing what
Ellie's do best is feeding their way
through the vegetation really
interesting to watch them at the moment
their diet is very very day feeding of
all kinds of different things
watching them go from bush willows to
baby plants of varying descriptions
there's been a few led words that have
been eaten there's been all kinds of
things that they've been going after it
was a bit of grass there's been a few
tubers that have been trying to be dug
up it was even a big fallen over tree
that was pushed in our direction which
was very funny because she lifted this
massive tree with thorns and all and was
pushing it and it looked as though it
was going to land on our Chi and when I
say it was a fallen tree it was not a
small fallen tree it was probably I
would say maybe double the height of the
vehicle and I thought well this is not
going to end well because it might hit
the side of the car where she just
didn't give it enough force and she
pushed it and it got to the
perpendicular and then gravity took hold
but not in the way that she had intended
it took hold back towards her and ended
up hitting her square in the forehead
which she doesn't appreciate too much
others shouldn't really seem to face she
kind of just threw it off to the side
and then carried on with a day but it
was quite funny to watch because did not
go the way that she hadn't visited it
then after that we had this little baby
come along and this little guy is
probably the most relaxed baby elephants
I think I've ever seen at one point it
was about maybe two meters from the car
and mom wasn't exactly that close and
the circle and just fit its way right
towards us it didn't worry at all about
coming near the car which is quite
strange generally little babies they're
curious but they don't get too close
Alysha you say your day is perfect now
you've got well it's not the worst way
to start today as for sure starts an
afternoon
if a herd of elephants and a lipid
within the first two minutes of our
Safari really is not bad at all in fact
if you came out to Africa and had that
in your first two minutes of Safari you
would be considered very lucky so it has
been a wonderful start to our afternoon
I'm thoroughly enjoying the fact that
we've got little Hosanna back at the
camp he must have been behind that damn
wall you say afternoon and this morning
they just must have been missing him the
whole time I'm sure yesterday with those
alarm calls it was him but somehow
managed to miss him now there's a female
coming out in front of us that he's
heavily heavily pregnant look at how
swollen her abdomen is that's amazing so
you can see look at how she's bulging on
the sides there around her hip areas so
that's very cool to see very swollen I
wonder how far she is from giving birth
would be nice imagine we got a little
baby elephant being born in the next few
days that would be quite cool it's very
seldom that you're going to catch an
elephant giving birth most of the time
they give birth at night for some odd
reason I don't know why that is but it's
genuine generally that way maybe it's to
do with the fact that they can feel like
they're more undercover and that they
are in have a little bit more peace and
quiet but I would think that having
giving birth at night would be a lot
more dangerous with things like hyenas
and lions and those sorts milling about
but maybe you will find that they are
aware of the fact that predators are
around and the whole herd will help just
to protect this female as she gives
birth but very very soil and tummy quite
amazing how much it's protruding
so Jake yes maybe Elly's will suck their
trunks quite regularly you'll find that
they put it in their mouth and they suck
it quite lots and in fact if you go to
some of these elephants rehabilitation
areas you'll find that they actually if
you put your hand there
they suck on your hand quite regularly
and they and they'll put their own
trunks in and they'll suck each other's
trunks a little bit so they do do a lot
of that kind of thing and why they do it
I'm not quite sure maybe it's very
similar to have two two babies it just
you know simulates the same motion or
same behavior of suckling I don't know
but it's an interesting behavior for
sure but how amazing is that now Rickson
has just got an art and mobile and I
need to just quickly give him a update
because I think Sydney's still learning
the ropes with the game driver Adia
Rick's is a nice big herd of elephants
just on the western side of final
control and then there's wasana it's
Gary Dam
so here we go he just gave Rick's a
little update quickly and that's he can
then gets his Safari planned but while
we sit with our ILI's for a while longer
and thoroughly enjoying how relaxed this
here it is and I spend most of our teen
like I say with him while it's still
bright and sunny and while we do that
let's send you back across to Sydney and
Hassan and I wonder if he's gotten any
closer to those impalas Osama decided to
sleep at the moment unbelievable that
husana was so very much active wanting
to go and chase the impalas
but now our sauna looks completely
different as if it's not the one who was
that very active earlier on but the
behavior we are seeing now is normal
very normal to the cats what we nearly
saw when he was falling in love with the
Impala chasing the impalas is something
which is not normal because normally
they prefer to hunt when the Sun is cool
but now the Sun is very easy now he's
interested again maybe this something
again
every seen how fast these cats are it
was like completely flat and he woke up
at very fast speed
now he's aiming down there so let me
just try and see what he's aiming at you
can see that the fact that these cows
are relaxed
take care I didn't get the question very
well I just hear that you're asking
something to do with the whiskers
I am not too sure if the whiskers can
grow throughout their lives but the
whiskers are very much important they've
got a very very vital role because if
they don't have whiskers it becomes very
difficult for them to judge the space in
between the branches and in between the
stems so when these animals are hunting
and when also moving around they have
got to be guided by their whiskers
whiskers can be able to sense the space
in between the bushes
so if you look at the hairs by the ears
you'll see that they yes the heads of
the ears are very much hairy inside so
those has there may be assisting them in
order to call that a lot of sound
aim the lepers can run very fast they
can go up to 1994 a km/h so they can run
at about 24 meters per second so they
can be able to jump not to show in terms
of the meters but they can run very fast
and they can leap very high
maybe it's gonna show us if any of the
prey comes nearby we might see how fast
this leopard skin CO and they the meters
how the gap in between their legs
I'm still going to be here looking at
this cat but while I'm here looking for
the cat
James is busy looking for some of the
smaller things let's see what James has
got so far every time I come along this
little part of the reserve walking with
Herbert he goes something like this ish
madam four there's a big number here
which means you can't believe the size
of the Mamba that lives over here and
they're about five or six points around
the reserve that Herbert says that at
and this is one of them and that they're
roughly I'd say about all it's an inch
and a half is the width of this members
belly so you can see my finger there
that probably means of this member is in
the region of between Polly was between
six and eight feet long so he's a fairly
long fairly venomous snake
well him snake and he probably live
somewhere there are territorial of
course I mean he says that a member
lives here he does mean in these
environments and it could easily live
interesting easily live in this hole
come over here sit obviously if the
member comes back off quite fast right
here's a hole now I would have said that
that was a rodent hole but I wouldn't
say it's strongly enough for me to put
my hand down there
it looks like the hole of a gerbil a
bushveld gerbil yes in fact it is Jim
you say you no not you just a bit scary
but not you look at this you see this
stuff here that is from a rodent making
a nest so this rodent has cleared away a
spot I'm sure he's taking some of that
down into his nest
and he'll be down there I'm gonna poke
him with my stick but it would be quite
lucky that the member didn't discover
him they're very interesting okay
numbers of course would be hibernating I
put it in inverted commas because I'm
not convinced that's the right term for
what they do in the winter here yes they
go to sleep for a while if it gets cold
but it's probably about 80 degrees today
which is very pleasant and so they will
be out and about looking for things like
that
poor little gerbil to eat let's go back
to Tristan and is much larger things
than gerbils well it's very very cool
that you guys have joined us right now
because there's some really interesting
behavior taking place what you can see
is a little baby elephant that's busy
eating the dung of its mother so we
don't often get to see this at all but
it's very common in elephants when the
little babies what they'll do is once
the mother goes to the vital bacterias
that they'll put into their stomach so
as they eat that they're getting all
kinds of things that are being added to
their digestive system which are going
to help them digest the different things
that they eat through their life and
it's vitally important that baby Ellie's
do this in fact baby areas that don't do
this and don't get a chance to if their
mom dies before they get a chance to do
this or very very seldom will actually
survive because they don't get all the
antibodies that they need and all the
different types of bits of goodness
should we call it that they need from
their tongue but it's not often you see
it at all
normally you kind of watch them and
they'll take maybe a little mouthful but
this little one has been feeding off it
for a good five minutes or so so I'm so
glad that we got to see it it's not
something that I've seen in a very long
time for this length or lips period that
it's been doing it for that length of
time is very very cool to see and that
little babies benefiting it sounds
really gross but it's very important for
them to be able to do this and to be
able to get all of the nutrients from it
so Paula you say oh well don't worry
it's not just them that does this
there's a few other animals that do and
scrub here survive pretty much you're
eating there in dung every single day so
it's not something that is goes well
with us but remember also that they are
have a very
different diets to carnivores and to
even omnivores there's lot less harmful
bacteria in a vegetarian based diet
these guys are eating any you know
grasses and leaves and branches and so
there isn't really not that much that's
bad inside us that's why we can as
people pick up their dung and break it
apart and look in it and kind of
scrounge through it if we were you
wouldn't really do that with anything
other than these big vegetarian based
animals so you know if you did that with
something like I you know our line
you're asking for a lot of trouble
you're gonna end up in a situation where
you're gonna get very bad bacterias on
your hand and you're going to make
yourself extremely ill if you go digging
around in line poop or something like
that it's much better for these
vegetarians to be able to do it so very
interesting so cats there's a very
simple reason why the Ellie's do not get
names but the big cats do is that
Ellie's are not territorial and if you
would like to name twenty thousand
elephants you're more than welcome
because I'm pretty sure that's
recognizing twenty thousand individuals
would be beyond the scope of 99.9% of us
guides none of us have got majorly big
brains and that would be very difficult
for us to be able to sort out one from
another so that's pretty much the reason
is that they are in a there's too many
to name them it's like imagine trying to
name every single Impala and recognizing
every single one of them it would be
very difficult wait where elephants do
get names is when it's big Tuskers so
Fang for example she's got a name and
short trunk those are two individuals
that we recognize very easily and you
know they've got one has got very big
tusks that two faces backwards and the
other ones with the shortened trunk but
in the Kruger Park system or any system
they're all the named that elephants are
either Tuskers so the individuals that
have massive tusks or the potential to
have really big tusks or they are
individuals that have some sorts of
story behind them that's allowed that
name to develop but it's not something
that we do very often and that's pretty
much the reason why is is one because is
too many - because they're not
territorial and that means that we might
see this herd today but we don't see
this herd again for six months enter
recognize that specific individual six
months later is very difficult so faith
sorry coming through very soft and I
missed the name
sorry faith I can't get the name at all
it is really struggling with it but
essentially the Craig can you hear that
because I can't hear anything anyway so
the question was I can't get the name
but the question was along the lines of
does the baby really have to eat its
mother's dangle can it eat any adults
tongue so generally you'll find with
little baby Ellie's is that they only
eat their mother's tongue because then
they normally very close to their mom
and so that makes it much easier for
them to be able to feed off that and be
able to you know get the nutrients from
her it's much harder for them to go and
get a situation where they find other
individuals dying it's it's quick and
easy just to go behind moms as she drops
and feeds off that and so I'm pretty
sure that with the Milka she provides
and the herd dang it's probably a better
recipe for them to be feeding off that
but it's not really stopping them from
eating others wonder if it would be in
any way different if they ate somebody
else's in whether it would be different
if they ate male or female dung I'm not
sure to the answer to that to be honest
I there might be somebody that studied
it but I don't know I've never seen a
little baby eating another members dung
it's only ever from their mom so it must
just be hardwired into them that they
only have that trust relationship to eat
their mom's poo not somebody else's but
that's one of the young Bulls that's on
the fringes of the hood the hood is
slowly but surely kind of going over the
road now they're heading towards
quarantine and I'm hoping that the whole
herd pushes on to quarantine and we'll
be able to get them all together and
we'll be able to see how many are
actually here because it is a nice size
her there's still more coming from the
northern side heading south and so I
reckon there must be at least 25 to 30
individuals here maybe more which is
very
it's always nice to have big herds good
well our knees are still feeding and
still being quite busy but I think
Sydney is still with us on and I wonder
if he stole as sleepy as he was the last
time we saw him a beautiful elephant
sighting feeding and learning about the
little ones eating droppings of their
mothers I am still here with us Anna and
hisana I can see he doesn't have any
other plans this afternoon except having
a rest and I'm just thinking now that
after this sighting I'll be heading out
and see if I can find other interesting
things and come back at the right time
because I know cats later on they'll be
active I will find him he might go to
the water hole he's not very far away
from the water hole is just a couple of
meters away so now I think I must have
to give him time to rest and see if I
can find other interesting animals I did
observe the Bailey so I did look at the
bellies I can see that yeah chances of
him doing some hunting are very much
high and then we can go to Tristan and
see the baby elephants
well Sydney this baby elephant is having
probably the PPS day its ever had
because not only has it been eating poo
but it walked behind mom and mom just
well lifted its tail and decided to
plunk a big fat ball of poo on its
forehead so as you can see is a horrible
big stain of poo meltdown forehead now
I'm sorry to call and you need some
toilet paper to clean that up
that doesn't look ideal at all shame can
you imagine having somebody drop poop on
your head
what ideal I'm sorry I'm laughing at you
I know it's not funny but these things
happen don't worry
well we'll tell mom off for you so you
can see they right in front of the car
at the moment shame that one it's a bad
day like I say I mean not only do you
have to eat somebody's pee but when it
gets shoved on top of your head as well
it's not very clever either and so it
just goes to show walking behind an
elephant is never the safest place to be
because well they just are
uncontrollable in the way that they will
lift their tail and deposit their done
yes you are quite something
should we stop talking about you hmm
it really has gone everywhere not only
is it on its head but it's also all over
its front leg it's a shame poor thing
that's not a bad not a good day now look
at this elephant on the Left jets busy
digging for a route as also mom has gone
down and pushed her trunk and look you
see she's got the tuba did you see she
dug it up completely
now hopefully she's going to take it out
of her mouth again you can just see it
in between obviously there would be a
tree right away we don't want it to be
hopefully she's gonna move a step
forward and we'll be able to see it but
there's a massive tuba and she used a
tusk to dig it into the ground and then
lift it up and that's how she exposed
that to burn-in took it into her mouth
which is very interesting because we've
refined in a lot of these tubers lying
on the ground from the Enya she's now
got it between her trunk
did you see that absolutely amazing she
took her trunk and she twisted it and
then took her tusk and broke the roots
and was able to actually expose the
nutrients on the inside which is pretty
incredible
she's not turned in the wrong way and
I've got it he's too close to me on the
right hand side to start because I'm
going to startle them and push them away
but I'm hoping that she's gonna turn
again and we'll be able to actually see
her do it one more time but that was
amazing she basically used her trunk as
a device just to hold it and then
leveraged with her tusks to break open
their tube and to get to the nutrients
on the inside and she's still busy using
the trunk as a just a place to hold and
to keep things nice and stationary while
she feeds but there's a bit of that tuba
in the curve of her trunk currently
little baby don't walk there you have
you not learnt your lesson you're going
to get poo on your other side of your
head as well be careful well lesson
learned
do not walk behind an elephant and so
how we contemplate that let's send you
back across to James who I'm sure will
have something funny to say about being
pooped on for this poor little lady I
don't think that I have anything funny
to say about being pooped on I'm not
sure being pooped on is particularly
funny thing and this happens to somebody
else then it's utterly hilarious and
I've told you the story a few days ago
actually about a girlfriend I once had
who was covered in hard lead our dung
after she gave them fright and I thought
it thoroughly deserving on her part I
used the term karma when she came home
that evening wonderful day that was one
good day and years of bad ones
alrighty we have a HP here and obviously
it's a tree you can see that and I'm
going to put it to you viewers what tree
is this it is a Virginia obviously so
are you not getting any points for
getting the genus right I'm asking you
because I'm slightly confused as to the
species I think it's one of two and I'm
really not sure which I'm going to go
for so Judy H if you're watching you can
have a guess
Virgilio hot while you think about it
I'm going to extract a little bit of gum
from it then you say it's a toothpick
tree well yes I suppose it might be to
victory they also
apparently used to use these thorns for
gramophone needles if you can believe it
that is not the official botanical name
of course here is a little bit of amber
for which these what used to be called
acacia trees are famous and it is this
of course that all the bush babies are
going for at the moment so when we find
them at the night hop in the night
hopping between the trees we know that
this is what they're going for I'll eat
some it's not very good it's got a kind
of slightly no taste bitter taste to it
there's another big lot over here said
and this lot is being tended by ants now
I think it seeps this gum in order to
attract ants because by having the ants
here of course it will make they will
make a vague attempt to protect the tree
from browsing predators like giraffes
and impalas Paula it is not an acacia
anymore and it's a virtue Lea remember
we're not allowed to call our phone
trees occasions anymore the Australians
have taken that honor for themselves
which i think is a great leader
satisfying but anyway this used to be an
acacia but it's not a knob for no you
can see it's got very long thorns I
think it's one of two things I'll show
you one more thing in the tree before I
give you my theories because you are not
giving me any of your theories which is
making various all in my heart over here
in the middle of the tree is what looks
like a blue wax bills mist my only
problem was saying what looks like a
blue expose nest is that when I pull out
this feather over here
most definitely not the feather of a
blue wax bill
it looks like the feather of a night jar
perhaps and I wonder if the blue X ball
that made this nest
didn't find perhaps a carcass of a night
jar and used the feathers to line the
nest for its little babies if I was a
little bird I wouldn't mind being born
and blue wax bill because they have such
a very comfortable nest because if
you're born of Wahlberg's a little
something like that well you lie on
forms basically you may as well be one
of those people who lie on beds of nails
any guesses further their faith about
the specific name of this tree nothing
you've all given up okay well it is
Sunday afternoon I understand I think
that this is probably a and Virginia
lost the name now
splendid thorn what is the splendid
thorn is what was it called used to be
called acacia no it's gone anyway a
splendid thorn or a red thorn
Virgilio Gerardi i and the red thorn is
normally given the name because it's got
red ins to the twigs but I don't see any
bread ends really and it's quite it's
got very long forms so I think it
probably is a splendid thorn but it may
well be a different variety from the one
that we often see down on the river
there we are thank you
robust that's exactly what I was looking
for for chillier robusta was that you
googling faith or was it's a viewer Emma
Google well done Emma googling you've
done very well I think it's a virtually
a robusta they do come in a number of
varieties out here so that's what that
is
no well well they sort of are Nikita and
if I break a thorn off and try not to
impale my finger on it
there are animals that in fact will
sting the thorns and that stinging
causes that wood inside to form a spongy
material which i think is quite
nutritious but that's basically wood
that's basically cellulose and cellulose
is extremely difficult for any animal to
digest unless it has got cellulase in
its gut or bacteria to help it digest
the cellulose and you know I didn't
think it's particularly nutritious at
all
just while I was talking there if you
look oh that's so so I'll look over here
sit and you see there are a whole lot of
cocktailed
ants feeding on the gum Meireles
cocktailed because their tails are
cocked fantastic and we'll leave it at
virtually a robusta
I think Tristan's now hitting sort of
towards where we are let's go and find
out
I have got one of the very much
interesting tree here and I want to show
you something as this morning while I
was out on a guided walk there was a
question about the elephant ring barking
the tree so now I want to show you the
consequences of elephants doing that so
if you look at this tree this whole area
here the the back is not there let me go
around this tree and just try and see
how much bark is taken off so I can see
that is quite a very large piece of this
tree but these three is one of the trees
that has narrowly escaped death because
when looking here I can see that the
skin is coming back because this area
here was not was not touched by the
elephants is the one which is now
surviving this whole tree so look at how
big is this tree and then the small part
which is supporting this whole tree but
it is very difficult to tell if this
tree is going to be able to survive I
can promise you now the amount of
nutrients which is taken from the ground
up by this it will be survived this
whole tree so the elephants this is what
they do mostly now during the season if
we can check they damage caused by the
elephants during the dry season it's not
the same as the damage caused by the
elephants during the summer season
summer season the elephants
they feed from these branches and the
branches by summer season they are very
much nutritious and the leaves they have
got quite a lot of nutrients so during
the dry season the trees they will take
everything and withdraw everything back
under the ground by the roots and this
elephants because they have been here
for quite a long time they are adapting
quite a lot of strategies to overcome
the challenges with regards to the dry
season and all they are doing now is to
dig and uproot the trees and try to get
hold of those nutrients so now
by this season elephants they just
caused quite a lot of damage so now I
will be moving towards the eastern side
of the game reserve and see I just want
to go around the tree house them and see
if maybe there's anything going there to
drink because when the Sun is very hot
like these chances of animals going to
drink they are very much hi
[Music]
so now I am heading towards threes damn
let's go to Tristan and see some of the
elephants already they are starting
doing what I was talking about rink
barking in the trees well indeed Sydney
they are stripping vegetation on masts
and I haven't been too destructive I
suppose on trees just yet but I suppose
it's coming as we get into more wooded
areas will start to see that's the same
destruction that Sydney was pointing out
just now but rarely been a beautiful
sighting of these Ailey's and there must
be one of the most relaxed herds I've
seen in quite some time they've been
absolutely all around us all the time
and have not even blinked an eyelid as
they've been moving around the vehicle
we've had little babies up close we've
had moms walking right in near us and
there's been no sign whatsoever of the
herd even changing their behavior for
one second so super relaxed must have
spent a lot of time around vehicles our
cheer in the sabi sands that you can see
this female she's about as round as she
is tall at the moment and I was just
saying to Craig she reminds me a bit of
a hot day balloon at the moment because
she's got these little skinny legs that
go down and then this massive massive
body that is very very round at the
moment so she's going to be giving birth
I would imagine
fairly soon I don't think it'll be too
much longer and she'll be having her
little one somewhere now hopefully to be
somewhere where we can see it's being
born that would be very cool
sit hard I'm not sure if pregnant
Ailey's feed more suppose they would
have to wouldn't they in order to keep
the fetus growing and to make sure that
there's enough nutrients I suppose there
would be a case for that it would
interest me because obviously with
Ellie's is that we know in winter
periods that their food intake goes up
so when it's summer Perez they'll only
eat about four percent of their body
weight because during that period most
of the vegetation around she has far
more nutrient rich and full of water and
full of all the things that they need
it's fresh green growth whereas in
winter it tends to go up to over six
percent of their body weight is what
they feed on because of how much less
they're actually getting out of the food
that they're putting in and so I would
imagine when they're pregnant they might
have to add a little 1% there somewhere
just to be able to absorb as much
nutrients as possible and be able to
provide for that little one so that it
grows nice and healthy inside before it
is born and be interesting I'm not 100%
sure if it is the case I surmise that
there might be a slight increase in
their intake but I don't know to be
honest isn't that beautiful
such a gentle giant
well done Craig very nice
so Marguerite's are no elephants don't
go off by themselves to give birth they
they will not go and find a thicket in
order to go and hide and do what they
need to you'll you'll see you with
elephants it's a little bit different
it's not quite the same as some of the
antelopes normally with elephants they
won't be far from the herd there'll be
quite close by they'll give birth and as
soon as they drop all of the other ideas
start rushing in and they'll form this
massive circle around this little baby
and nobody lots of touching and feeling
and vocalizing it really is an amazing
thing to witness
so she'll break apart slightly oh and
when we talk she moves away we took him
maybe 20 30 meters she doesn't go far
from the herd at all and the reason why
she won't go far is because she has to
be able to provide protection for that
little one but whilst she's giving birth
she's going to be very vulnerable she's
going to be you know in a situation
where she's squatting she's trying to
have this baby and she's not able to
actually defend herself as well as she
probably would be if she wasn't giving
birth and so the rest of the herd is
there as a protection basically they're
there to keep everything away and
predators at bay and then they're able
to come in and protect the if there is a
predator in nearby or you know just to
stand guard in case and so she won't
move too far away or she won't also give
birth rights in the middle of everybody
because she does require a little bit of
privacy so normally just off to the edge
and then the rest of them come in as
soon as she gives birth as soon as
there's that moment where the baby drops
and you'll hear lots of vocalizing then
everybody comes in and investigates
what's going on in welcomes this new
little one to the world all right
now I think I'm probably gonna stay with
my Ellie's a little while longer because
they bats go into quarantine it's gonna
be super beautiful to watch them
coasting through this winter grass and
so while I do that it sends you back
across to Sydney who I think is with a
bird now from the elephants to the
lizard bar that you can see I've got a
juvenile lizard Buzzard a and I want to
tell you a story about this lizard
Buzzard and this happened while I was
proved very young I was a very good
hunter and I used to walk around with my
kitties the catapults and I used to hunt
this bears a lot at one stage I shot one
of the lizard buzzards and then he fell
of the ground when I picked up that bird
it was before he was still alive and
kicking and I thought he's dead and this
is what this bird did to me today if you
can check here on my second finger right
finger I've got a scratch here this
scratch it was opened by the talons of
this lizard buzzer their talons are very
sharp and then I was opened here now
when I do any kind of fingerprint I have
got a lizard Buzzard scratch there and
is appearing all the time so now it's
becoming permanent so it's just that
it's difficult to see the Telos day so
these bears they normally target the
lasers so they normally to get the
lasers and they also take some of the
other in some other rodents as well as
part of the food
Larina a lizard Buzzard
is what you are seeing now is one of the
very beautiful person this is my first
sighting in Juma since I have arrived
3-4 weeks ago and they are very much shy
so this is quite a very good sighting
Safari South they call these bears make
is like so it's quite a very a Trista
cold but they they whistle each the
width of it you will hear something like
[Music]
so if you hear it then it translate it
into a sound just like that is how the
recall but these are the small bears
they can be able to identify their
course when they hear and lizard
bothered calling they rod so they know
they fly away so now I'm going to be so
now I will be heading towards the tree
house damn and let's see James is out on
a guided walk maybe James has got
something already let's see we've got
tracks of tündi and we pretty much
backtracking her because we think she's
left the baby in here also looks like
this is the block from which your sauna
came so it's quite possible that all
three of them were together yet again we
don't think we're very close all the
little one is hiding because there's
some Impala just two here so let's walk
slowly along yes
the little one of course nine months old
as I've said to you before is not very
confiding with human beings on foot
unlike wasana was at the same age and
his sister shakila they just used to
very comfortably hang around and we were
there I think it's a darker it's down
through this riverbed quietly carefully
margarita learning the animal tracks is
not actually that difficult you know
they're not that many mammals here
probably but I don't know a total mammal
counter around about thirty if you
exclude the bets and the gerbils and
things which of course very difficult to
check and you can learn insect tracks
and frog tracks and that sort of thing
learning shapes is not that hard you
know you can do it in probably couple
weeks the difficulty comes of course
when you walk across an area like this
and our sudden you don't have a clear
track you've got a very indistinct track
of an antelope
but because that this is sand it's quite
difficult to tell which antelope it was
unless you have a lot of experience so
now suddenly you're weeks of track
learning have exploded in two years of
figuring out what different tracks look
like in different substrate so that's
one thing and for me most people can
make a an almost disc topped study of
tracking of track identification anyone
can learn to do it really doesn't take a
huge amount more then the keen interest
a good tracking book in a bit of time on
foot in an area like this and then you
could learn to identify all the
different tracks the real skill for me
and the skill that I profoundly lack
possibly but I like to use excuse of a
slight visionary deficiency but the real
skill is following these tracks and to
spot them or in areas where you know
most of us wouldn't see a track someone
like her but he's been doing this for
decades decades is able to follow them
now is writing a little article today on
a chap called Linnaeus Matt Anjana and
bumble who came up here about two years
ago now to do a little tracking
intervention with us and he and his he's
a my friend Alex London here for run
something called the tracker Academy and
they're they teach tracking but to walk
with a guy like Irenaeus or with Herbert
used to understand that this is you know
it's PhD level skill that these people
present possess it's not something you
decide that I'm going to learn to do one
day and then you suddenly you know a few
weeks later you can track it is decades
of walking through difficult areas
trying to spot tracks trial and error
trial and error endless patience and so
you know there really is a huge scale
there's a huge difference between what
would call a level one tracker and what
would call a master tracker it'll take
you about four or five days of you know
we could teach you a level one tracking
in a couple of weeks very easily devil
to take a bit longer because you have to
be able to follow a little bit and a
level three is it exponentially more
difficult than than to be a level two
tracker in level in level two basically
what they make you do is you've got
identify some brain it's a very
difficult tracks but you've got to be
able to follow something like a rhino
and find it that's not difficult level
three you ought to be able to follow
something like a lion I can't get
through here and skipper all this way
you will build for something like the
lion which is not more difficult and you
know senior or master tracker evaluation
its leopard these leopards and it
slippers through difficult terrain might
even be something as obscures a stim
book through hard rocky Carew land and
that's decade's worth of of experience
I believe that Tristan has either broken
down or he's just taking very leisurely
Sunday afternoon with his elephants I am
having a leisurely Sunday afternoon why
not it's it's not you know been a while
since I've spent all afternoon with
Elias and so I thought it would be very
nice to spend a leisurely afternoon with
a really peaceful Hood but the reason
why I also stayed a little bit is
because I wanted to show you just how
long grass can actually get here in Juma
often you know it's difficult to give
you a sense of scale but there is an
elephant and you can see the grass next
to it is about the same height as its
eyes maybe a little bit higher than that
this is not a fully grown elephant this
is probably about I would say maybe a 12
13 year old but still it is incredibly
tall if I had to stand it it would be
well over my head that grass and so
there are patches of the sketching grass
is called yellow thatching grass that
gets that long and you get some areas if
you go down into the central parts of
the sabi sands and along singita London
AZ area along the railway line the old
celerity railway line you get a lot of
this yellow fetching grass in those
areas and you get big fields of it you
can walk there with your with somebody
and you'll literally lose them within a
meter because the grass is so high and
so thick and it becomes very difficult
to see anything that's going on and
funny enough you find not many animals
actually spent time in it it's one is
not very tasty at all it's it lacks a
lot of nutrients and it's not really a
nice species of grass for animals to eat
and to you'll find that it's very
difficult for anybody to actually spot
anything so producers don't use it
because I can't see anything and the
prey don't use it because they can't see
the Predators so it's a bit of a barren
area we're lucky here that we don't have
too many fields of the statue in grass
we only have small little sections just
off quarantine it's quite strange
actually how few areas we do have of
fetching grass and it's because we don't
have many areas that are cleared or
mowed or anything like that sits in
areas where I've cleared that you'll see
attaching grass developing if it's over
grazed and the likes
but very cool to have spent the
afternoon so far with these guys I'm
thoroughly enjoying spending time with
them Tom well suggests maybe it's time
to invest in a lawn mower or a weed
whacker if that your backyard looks like
that unless of course you want your
backyard to look like that maybe you
have a situation you want to have long
grass and have I don't know why you'd
want actually fetching grass in this
it's a farm area I don't know or maybe
you like the wilderness feel in your
backyard but otherwise if you don't then
a lawn mower or a weed whacker is
definitely recommended I can highly
recommend certain brands they do quite
well Craig is actually a very good weed
whacker with a slash in handy it's an
unknown skill of Craig's he doesn't
actually let many people know about this
but you give him a blade and he just
slashes grass like a machine in fact in
tomará
craig was very very good at slashing
grass weren't you Craig yeah Craig is
not impressed by me saying that he's a
good slasher of grass at all but this is
a skill I don't know if many of you have
ever slash cross it's not that much fun
it's in here in Africa often involves
basically a long play that is plugged
into a handle that you sharpen at the
end and the blade comes down and then
hazard it sort of angles Art's not quite
at right angle but very close to and
that's that in gets sharpened and then
you have this swinging motion and the
best way a lot of them are a staff told
me is that you tuck one hands of a hand
your back and you hold it behind and
then with a swinging motion from left to
right you slash through the grass and it
doesn't sound like much if it's in the
first few swings you think of this is
child's play I can do this all day but
after one hour of slashing your arm
feels as though it's about to break off
and your shoulder starts to get tired
and it really is quite strenuous work
and it amazes me how some people are
able to do it I've seen people do it for
eight hours straight without really
giving it too much of a second thoughts
and it's it's not easy work at all and
not something that you want to be doing
every day I can promise you that but
it's amazing how effective it is to that
little blade being
wrong back and forth can shorten grass
in a moment's notice brains actually is
pretty good at it I'm quite surprised
how brain turn squat they both have a
good technique and use it quite well
brain stirs technique has faded somewhat
over the last few years with his hip
becoming a bit dodgy so he's not quite
as able to swing his hip around not that
that stops him trying to be act like a
hooligan half the time but you know he's
not as nimble as he used to be so Amy no
the the elephants won't use the grass to
hide from predators they really don't
have to stress too much about predators
particularly in this area here in the
sabi sands you know there's so many
other prey animals Archer that it would
only take the most hardened of predators
to try go after an elephant and and
maybe hardened and stupid would be
another way to put it because elephants
are incredibly dangerous when they are
ticked off and they will chase anything
that comes near them particularly in big
family groups like this there's very few
predators that would even remotely try
get close to a herd like this unless
there was a very badly injured
individual or a baby that was maybe
stillborn or was deformed in some way
then maybe they would try but they
wouldn't use grass to hide them they
would use their strength and their
numbers in order to defend themselves
against predators and that's how they do
it there's been a video going around
recently on various social media areas
of a sighting just to the west of us a
few days ago of wild dogs and hyenas
having interaction and an elephant herd
coming in and you want to see just how
angry elephants can get with predators I
suggest you take a look at that video
because they seriously lose the plot and
they'll chase things all over the place
and defend their little ones as to the
best of their ability and so they don't
really rely on camouflage to protect
themselves that's why they also can walk
out in the open they can walk in the
thickets they can walk me anywhere they
want to day night and they don't really
have too much to worry about in saying
that though in other parts of Africa and
so in some areas where a lot of the
other prey animals are not so so
numerous you'll see that predators will
start targeting elephants particularly
young males that have just been kicked
out of herds so those 12 to 15 year old
males that are no longer have the
protection of the herd
they will then get pushed out by will
gets chased by lines in particular and
sometimes even big hyena clans so that
does happen from time to time but it's
it's not that common
now I can hear Franklin's that are alarm
calling and I've heard them quite long
now normally a Franklin does an alarm
call for very long at all but I can hear
them just north of us still making a bit
of noise and I know that ting ghana's
tracks was somewhere around here so I
wonder if ting Ghana's not creeping
around in the background of this herd is
pretty much just to their back right of
where that elephant is so in that
section up there is where it's coming
from it's just this low squeak from
these Franklin's it's the alarm call
that they have it could have been a bird
of prey that came over but it also could
have been a lipid that's maybe moving
around this I'm not going to investigate
that now that's our eddies are having
fun I just turned over my shoulder and
watch the little baby Andy take a cup of
grass and throw it into the a and as
though it just wanted to have fun I
don't know what it's doing okay can you
see that one over there on the right so
that's little one in there is having the
best time throwing grass all over the
place as you can see look do you think
it's wanting to test the wind let's see
if it's going to do it again is that
poopy that's what I've nicknamed this
elephant by the way the one that got
pooped on is its name is poopy so we
need to come up with some sort of
marking that we can recognize it and
then whenever we see it we'll just call
it peepee now but this one is having the
best time with this tuft of grass it's
been put on its head it's being thrown
into the air what are you doing well I
suppose if one is bored a big clump of
grass for an elephant is tossed around
to a Playstation for a kid these days
well we have just been covered in gas of
well yes from a elephant that is upwind
from us it's lovely smell it has drifted
on towards us it really has been a
delightful experience being in this herd
today we've seen all kinds of
interesting behavior that relates to the
rear end and so while we contemplate
whether or not to be actually gonna
stick around after being well farted on
is there any way to put it
let's send you across to Sydney who's
got another very iconic animal from
Africa
so this year after the just very much it
legs trying to have something to eat
it's quite a lot of them here if you
look at that giraffe nicely the one
right in the camera now the one looking
at us when is feeding looking at that
side just check behind the ears behind
the ears this giraffe is bright white
look at that that bright white colors
you are seeing there it is there for
communication the whole body is
camouflaged except there so that is the
part which is left for this giraffe to
communicate so giraffes when they are
feeding the experience problems
sometimes because these trees some of
them they attract the ants and ants they
act as the trees bodyguards big animals
such as the elephants and giraffes they
always try by all means to avoid the
trees which has got a lot of ants
because ants can be able to enter
sensitive areas such as the nostrils
that is why when the giraffe is feeding
you will see him every time bringing out
the tongue and what he's doing now
he does that you will see him trying to
bring out the tongue and touch the nose
every time so that is when he is also
trying to get rid of the ants he have
just shown us now were lucky to see that
so when is feeding some of the things
when they come to the nostrils he must
have to be able to take them out
giraffe girl giraffes are very much
interesting I'm very happy to see that
you like them a lot and you are so happy
to see them this afternoon so look at
that that animal each one of them has
got its own striped pattern by looking
at the stomach look at that stomach look
very much big on that one it's difficult
to tell where I am here but that one to
me looks a little bit a pregnant
these animals can be pregnant for about
six fifteen to sixteen month so I cannot
see very well but from here where I am
that stomach is looking having something
inside so these animals they give birth
while they're standing they are like the
elephants the little one has to hit the
ground as a wake-up call in order to
kick-start their lives you see the line
you are seeing now that Mane which is
growing up to the head when that main is
is flat sleeping
it means the giraffe is experiencing
challenges normally is when the giraffe
is lacking of calcium in other words you
can be able to tell from the main that
mane can serve as a gauge in order to
tell the health status of these animals
w James yes there is quite a lot of
different giraffes and occurring here in
Africa but here in Juma Game Reserve we
have got only one specie which is the
one that you are seeing now not too sure
what exactly this animal is but now I'm
going to pull forward and see if we can
have a better sighting as now I have
just lost the sighting just now so for
us to see them better I want to try and
go around
I've got one just right in front of me
they're trying to avoid me as well so
it's going to join the family so a group
of giraffes together is called a cops of
giraffes yeah they are like cops you
know they can see they are very much
observations
so I'm just gonna try and cross this
drainage line and get to the other side
you can see that giraffe there is trying
to leave behind the droppings so see
that he loves they don't stop
in order to excrete the droppings they
defecate as they are moving that is why
their droppings you'll see them just
scattered everywhere sometimes I'm just
gonna try and and position myself so now
while I'm going to the other side let's
see James out on guided walk let's see
what is experiencing I'm looking at an
oblong tree remember we had a little
chat about the virgilia's and the
occasions I just thought I'd remind
those of you who are interested in this
sort of thing this is a knob form and it
is no longer in acacia anymore either
but it's not a virtue Leah it's the
Senegal ear and the Senegal ears are the
ones with the little hooked forms as
opposed to the white thorns the long
white forms this is got small hooked
thorns and so it is not a virtue Leah
not an acacia anymore but a Senegal ear
and this is a great example of an odd
form
Sebastian why is it a great example of
an odd form because it has a lot of
knobs exactly come over here see the
knobs there are all of the knobs
knob is a good word to say everybody if
you're feeling little Sunday blues issue
at the moment say knob a few times
you'll feel much better knob knob knob
form now these knobs are used
extensively in traditional medicine and
for one of those things is to take one
of the things that they use them for are
for toothache and you break off a knob
crush it up and put it on the Sawtooth
and apparently it takes the pain away I
unlike Sydney have been a victim of
Western medicine in many respects during
my growth so I haven't tried this I
don't know if it works or not suddenly
well to tell you if it does
in sting I think Sydney has actually got
the most amazing balance between sort of
traditional and Western medicines I find
obviously many much of my experience
with Western medicine has given me the
impression that we totally overmedicate
we don't treat sickness we treat symptom
which is very different from what
happens out here Bobby Bob is also nice
word to say if you're feeling sad bob
nobb Bobby I don't think thorns have
ever been used for fishing really except
to make fishing nets for fishing baskets
people used to make fishing baskets out
here but the thorns are but they don't
hook they can't be bent and so you know
they're but brittle to be used for
fishing you know you know with a line I
suppose you might catch a very small
fish on the end of a very small spear
with one of these thorns birth they've
ever been used for fishing fishing here
with fishing baskets made from sometimes
thorny branches and then they're placed
in a current where there will be fish
otherwise fishing done here with poison
you can take the the fruits of the
balanitis tree or the torchwood tree you
can crush those up and make a sort of
solution with them pour it in water
where you know they're fish and the fish
will float to the top belly-up
that means dead now in fact you can
still eat them because what is you know
as long as you get them properly the
poison doesn't take the meat here we
have another example of an odd phone you
see if I can break one of these off I
did have a toothache once and I don't
have a tooth anymore did you know that
special I had to take the 2000
now I didn't do myself no no I had a
professional dirt list I must confess of
all Western medicines achievements in
comparison with traditional medicine I
would imagine that the advancement of
local anaesthetic substantially more
impressive in towns come back the more
they are quite favored by elephants but
let's carry on through here yes I
wouldn't fancy having my tooth out
you've given me the choice between
having my mm Sydney's place or in
Johannesburg I'd go with Johannesburg
there are many others many other
situations I choose to be in Sydney's
place but not that I'm just going to
have a small snack it's a very fresh
dizzy force bush and very unusual
because of course why is it growing now
in the driest part of the year I don't
know also another nice word to say for
feeling sad dizzy force so if you can
say as easy for Bob and knob nor feel
better and Rosalind I have not seen a
lot of snakes around here ever I've seen
a lot of snake tracks you must remember
that snakes dislike us more than we
dislike them well some of us just like
them and so they just stay away from us
although we see their tracks all over
the place we share they stay away from
us all right now what we're doing at the
moment
apart from sort of wandering along
finding little bits of pieces of
interesting flora is that we are walking
the northern and southern sides of this
depression here this gully and the
Scully weren't possibly has in it tongue
till our head has ended Caramba
Tandy came wandering through here we've
had her tracks she's turned on and gone
out she doesn't have the baby with her
so baby isn't very likely somewhere in
here that's why we were wandering around
him alrighty we'll continue on that
mission and let's go across to Tristan
who has now
doing the most amazing thing driving I
am driving James and I'm doing it to the
best of my ability so far better then I
have according to my previous record
which was falling out of the car so if I
haven't done that so Craig are you
laughing at me
Craig is giggling behind the lens do you
find that funny Craig did you enjoy that
when I fell out yes you did
I believe so so anyway Craig thinks it's
funny that I fell out maybe that's
because I told him that he's a goodness
Cross /up anyway we've left our it is as
you probably saw there was a Lee's on
both sides the road as we were driving
out so we've decided to give our any
heard a break from our presence or so we
were a little bit over being farted on
by a certain individual who has got a
very dodgy stomach and the wafting gas
that kept hitting us in the face because
he was upwind what's a little bit much
and so we've decided now it's going to
investigate what these Franklin's were
squeaking about maybe we'll find a very
dozy juke somewhere around here that's
what I'm hoping for I'm hoping he's
walking around and if nothing here then
we'll head off towards the east and
maybe see if there's any sign of Tandy
and little one given that James has got
the tracks
Gary no not necessarily I mean we winter
has been been an interesting winter
because it's very warm today it's it's
very pleasant and doesn't feel it's all
like a winter's day and then it's very
dry and a bit windy but otherwise it's
actually quite nice so we're not in a
heatwave although Louise told me today
earlier say she said that it's going to
be quite hot this week and there's going
to be a period - it's going to go over
32 degrees which is very warm so that it
could be considered warm for winter but
we're very lucky oh there's some dwarf
Mongoose can you see them um we're very
lucky that we have a fairly temperate
winter although this winter has been
extremely cold early in the mornings
we've had a few morning's where we've
really had to wrap up and in quite cold
temperatures so it's gonna be
interesting to see if it was just a cold
phase that we had and if it's gonna just
disappear or if we're gonna have a you
know a sort of break from the cold and
then all of a sudden the cold is going
to come in be interesting to see how it
plays out so I'm never one that's good
with weather and I suppose it's a good
job to be a with a man I feel like it's
the one job where you can be wrong 90%
of the time and no one tells you that
you are failing at your job you just
okay well it didn't rain today so what
you know it's not one of those things
where if you exactly so faith is
agreeing with me she says there's you
know performance review must be quite
difficult with the way the man so you
said it was going to rain and it didn't
know well guess what that's what it is
and I obviously I'm just messing around
because I actually know that guys that
do you wear that or very very
intelligent people that do a lot of
studying and they look at all kinds of
charts and graphs and maps and all kinds
of things to be able to make the
predictions that they do and obviously
we know with nature nothing is really
that predictable and so it's it's not
really a surprise that they don't get it
right all the time but they do put in a
lot of effort and in no way am i what
would be the word diminishing their
profession and making it sound like they
are no good I just think it's funny that
you can be wrong so often and does
anyone actually shout at them I want I
want to actually know is anyone
where the man hashtag Safari live if you
have done weather or you're a
climatologist and whether or not you get
into trouble if and when you get it
wrong
when it comes to predicting weather
because I don't know I'm just wondering
what do you think Craig do you think
people get shot of that if they get to
weigh their um oh well okay Craig I
don't know either so I guess we're in
the same boat today so he just came to
Galago pan quickly because I thought
maybe just maybe 10 Ghana might have
made an appearance here and had himself
a little drink but there is absolutely
nothing as you can see it is barren as
barren can be there is just a puddle of
water in the middle of that Baroness and
says has not attracted lipid like we had
hoped no good anyway talking about
attracting a lipid it sounds like Sydney
is driving I wonder if he's on his way
back to hosana
I am now heading back to see if there's
any development with regard to a
hosannas resting
maybe asana is up now trying to look for
something or going to the waterhole so
I'm just gonna pass by there and try and
see if there's any other development I
am heading there now
I'm just very close by I'm just about a
minute away from where we left him early
on so he was right on the other side of
the dam here so I'm just gonna go over
the dam wall and see if he still writes
today
I am not seeing anything yet
it moved he is not there where I left
him alias I've got to oh there is he I
can see him now someone in the middle so
I'm just gonna go around and see if we
can have a better sighting he's very
much relaxed at the moment so we're
gonna have a good sighting now because
he's not lying down flat anymore
they did not move for a long distance it
just moved a little bit
the next muffin girl that is true is
Posey you can see how it's like they're
his living positions right towards the
damn camera
so there's no other activities expect
except asana here all the animals they
are now trying to avoid this area maybe
they will come back later on but it
seems like asana is prepared to
challenge anything coming here look at
that it seems like he was just waiting
for me
that's quite a very beautiful cat so I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna try and follow
him now
Michelle yes he is very much aware and
is very much alert because he is by the
open areas whereby anything can chance
to happen so I just want to try and
catch up and catch him again as he just
moved towards this direction I can see
him from here
I'm not too sure is trying to look for
something I'm not sure if he's aiming at
beds or something there
beautiful I thought he was going to
attack something so you can hear the
best already now they're giving signals
they are alarming about his presence so
this kind of best they do helped us a
lot
while out on guided walks they tell us
the presence of these cats you can see
now he is laying down flat and is
matching the grass
jerison that is very true indeed hasanah
he is getting bigger and bigger every
day you can see that was a nice eating a
very good meal every time so those beds
that are just making noise here the most
of them they nest on the ground look at
that this is beautiful this is very much
you can see that it's interesting how
cats entertain themselves
so most of these bears make noise here
are those bears nesting on the ground
and one of these beds I'm seeing they're
the one which is doing its tit please
that is one of the very most aggressive
bears I will just show you that bad now
that one is called the blacksmith plover
this bears they have got something which
is called a destructive behavior when
something is walking towards their nest
if it's one of the predators such as
bears at the bed you will see they will
try by all means and fly as if they've
got a broken wing just to try and
confuse the predator to come for an easy
meal they act as if they've got a broken
wing and predator concentrate on that
and think about getting that big meal
and then when they get there they fly
away which becomes then very difficult
for the predator to reallocate where
they were which was maybe very close to
the nest look at husana now done with
some entertainment going up he might be
going to the dam because it's not very
far now
this is very beautiful so soon as he get
up there I'm gonna try and see if we can
have a better visual not in Palestine
normally these areas in Paris are
feeding here because it's more open and
they can easily see the predators coming
from far today is just by himself look
at that is difficult to even figure it
out that they see a cat in those glasses
so this this cat is very clever because
it's using this dam to attract the prey
so I think here is where husana is
killing quite a lot of animals
so I just want to try and follow him and
see if we can
I just want to try and follow him and
see if we can have a better visual
because I can see that now from here
where I am it's not easy it's quite
difficult to see him
so while I'm looking for the better
position let's see what James is doing
with the ash bag yes
I'm displaying my ash back my ass bag is
out my ash bag is out because we think
there are elephants nearby good when
this blend well frost stole from the
northwest
we heard their ears again Oscar
rabbits just looking in here we had more
tracks of the leopard we think and we
think she headed in here but three
things that she may actually be avoiding
us that we you know kind of made too
much noise we've come along anyway
elephants will be magnificent on foot
probably in this riverbed wind is good
fast flowing into our faces
Marguerita in some places there is over
harvesting of medicinal trees not in
this area though I mean this is a game
reserve so people aren't allowed to come
on to this area and just harvest trees
willy-nilly so no not really here but in
common in the Commons I guess in the
areas of communal lands yeah absolutely
many trees and many species have been
denuded through traditional medicine
yeah we've gotten there we go this would
be a nice sighting because we've what's
the height afforded by this riverbed is
the first view we'll carry on and get it
closer look now
that was me giving a thumbs up for an
action broadcast
good afternoon everybody and welcome on
this magnificent Sunday to the Western
burger park we're standing here on foot
with the Nell ephant my name is James
Henry Sebastian jambe his on camera and
we're sitting with a gorgeous elephant
bull now he's sitting there just feeding
he's not sitting actually he's walking I
can't see any others and it is the most
glorious late summers at least late
winter's afternoon here please ask us
any questions you'd like to in a sit
very quietly
and just enjoy being close to the
world's largest land mammal there are in
fact more of them I can hear another one
further wood from where he is I'd say
that that bull was probably in the
region of 30 years or so he's a big
fellow
and as he had completely unaware of our
presence we'll try and keep it that way
him perfectly positioned for wind not so
ideally positioned for light if he
doesn't look this way you'll see us
because the sun is shining on us but we
are between him and a gully and so we're
quite safe at this stage Jeremy it can
be a little scary being this close on
foot but you know I've been working out
here for a long time now and why I
always have a very healthy respect for
these animals the terror I used to feel
when seeing them on foot is not
dissipated and now I feel much more
wonder than I do terror we're also in a
pretty good position here where we're
safe there's this gully between him and
us he's obviously very calm the wind is
in our favor there's lots of cover for
us to move to so we're not in the
threatened position and likewise he's
not gonna feel threatened if he does see
us he'll probably move off if she
doesn't buckets or he'll just stay doing
exactly what it's doing now and ignore
us
the chances of him turning on and coming
towards us very slim indeed Kalyan it
really depends as I say I've said this
before to a few people you know being on
foot with animals means that you don't
ever get quite as close while you try
not to get quite as close as you might
in a vehicle but it's not really about
that so in a vehicle you can sit and
they'll min around and do whatever they
do almost without paying any attention
so you learned quite a lot about the
behavior this is a different kind of
experience now and this experience is
one of connection with the wild to me
seeing an elephant bull like this one
foot it makes me feel my in significance
it makes me feel really plugged into the
wilderness and that's why I like seeing
them on foot that's not the best view of
an elephant you'll ever have on alive
Safari but it's a view of an elephant
that we're getting on foot which is
tremendously tremendously special now I
will just tell you that there are
franklyn's
screaming their heads off behind us they
may well be a lipid around there as well
which would be quite exciting Mina yes
absolutely elephant trunks have got lots
of muscles in them you read things in
anecdotal texts that say a hundred
thousand different muscles yeah I don't
think it's quite that it's probably more
like a hundred thousand muscle fibers or
something like that but there is a lot
of very complicated musculature in an
elephant's trunk they are able to extend
them concertina style curl them all the
way around both ways at the same time
they are heavy and so they have to
maintain muscle structure without
becoming stretched and floppy
now some elephants do get something
called floppy trunk syndrome which is
really dangerous for them because it
means they don't can't use the trunk
properly but that's probably
neurological rather than muscular mmm
what's the word I'm looking for
other than muscular muscular muscular
yes yeah but there are very fine muscles
now Margaret at the moment I would say
that that elephant has no idea that we
here you may be able to hear the wind
blowing and if I show you which way the
winds blowing this is my ash bag it's a
sock full of air you can see that the
wind is blowing from the elephant to us
and that means the elephant will not
smell us and their eyesight is good
probably about as good as ours maybe
they're a little bit more myopic than
some but their eyesight is generally
pretty good and so I wouldn't say that
if he turned this way he wouldn't see us
but he hasn't turned this way we might
try a little bit of a walk along here
and just see if we can get a nice smooth
better view I'm gonna go around here you
just go on there sit I need to go
through here try not to catch the inside
of my thigh on this rather heavy thorn
bush
[Applause]
if you look up there sip you can see
that there's a tree about to be felled
either by an illegal wood chopper well
most likely by another elephant in fact
you can see the other elephant now their
gray ship moving through the sort of
greenish gray bush there's probably
another bull probably a little a
bachelor group of two you can move
around with more sip come on this way
[Applause]
this I from the look of those tusks I
would have said they're about four feet
long I think they're quite long it's a
big Tusker fur this of course doesn't
make him any more dangerous or less
dangerous there we go he's a big Bullis
that's a big a tall boy
I think he's older than 30 okay nice
seen us just watch him carefully what
you'll see is him lifting his head he's
turning to the left there and I he'll
probably if he doesn't turn all the way
around he'll turn the other way and look
at us through his right eye
watch now
nah he'll turn there we go
so he's seen us he's not that's not
ideal from our point of view we want to
view these animals so they don't know
that we here he's not in any way
irritated or threatened
he's just suddenly turning on Thor blue
there are whole lot of people there and
Sanai is just gonna melt off into the
bush that was very special wonderfully
relaxing connecting Sunday afternoon
experience thank you for joining us if
you want to watch the rest of our drive
you can just go to youtube
it's appeared as a fiery live and well
we've got somebody to sitting with the
leopard sydney sitting with a lipid and
tristan is looking for other lipids so
it's quite exciting we'll see you next
time
all right everybody we're gonna move on
to here there were some Franklin's going
mad up they were gonna check those out
Sydney stole Hosanna Hosanna is very
much a relaxed at the moment and I've
seen he has been looking around it seems
like their way is is normally he's
hiding position because he's aiming at
this side when I am and much more on the
other side so he's just very trying to
become afraid and see if maybe anything
is gonna come out but he's checking all
directions so today I have seen that
hasanah
is very much clever and is you slating
utilizing this dam in a little attracts
the animals for him to kill
it's not easy look at that it's moving
very quickly and the es as well
so this is very much beautiful I'm just
gonna look at him and see what he's
looking at because what I have learnt
about asana is that if I don't look at
him I won't see what is coming whenever
this something coming he will let me
know he's very much active early today
he might be hungry
look at that
is trying to become a fledged year it
seems like as good a mission Pilon that
is true asana is very much beautiful you
can see the rosette spots on him and the
pink nose make it worse
this is a beautiful animal
so while I'm waiting here for anything
to come I am going to share and go
through my other colleagues list and see
how these smaller animals are doing well
we have the training track at the moment
as you can see there is sprint training
happening right now with our little
dwarf longus grouping they are all
running around like absolute hooligans
it's a massive business of mongoose that
we've got yet is lots of them running
around all over the place like absolute
hooligans they've been running up and
down been sitting here for about ten
minutes and just watching them go from
one side of the road to the other up and
down the road so it's almost like a
training track this afternoon and
everybody's getting little bits of
exercise in it was quite funny there
watching them all cross the road and it
seems as though they've now disappeared
for good but let's see maybe when we
roll back down they will see them coming
back out again but that was quite cool
wasn't it nice to see our smallest
land-based carnivore they actually
haven't been too many around the blades
I've been looking out for them and I
haven't seen that amania just every now
and then to see them scuttling into the
grass but not as many as I thought I
would be seeing this time of the year
wonder what they've been up to on the
burnt area they probably all smell like
smoke they're going to go home and their
mothers are going to be very upset
because they're going to have to talk
Blackfeet that's oh can I leave can you
hear them
it's not everyday you get to hear these
guys look they playing you see that
they're having a little wrestling game
what are you guys up to I suppose it's
the end of the day and it's that time
when everybody has a bit of extra energy
Dixon is funny how they run isn't it I
always loved these guys when they run
around like little hooligans they kind
of back in bounces up a little bit they
must have a very similar run to an utter
in some respects artists or said that
kind of slinky bounce that they I don't
know why they'd have it like that I
suppose maybe it's because their bodies
are quite long they end up doing it but
that was very cool just to hear them
it's not like I say an animal we get to
hear very regularly you're you know
obviously we hear things like lions and
if it's sawing and roaring and those
kind of things but these guys they've
all come back hearts again and if we sit
you for long enough if they're going to
start playing again look at this it's
just you can see why they call it a
business of Mongoose because it's never
quiet they will just go all over the
place all the time wonderful there isn't
it this is the thing you know we often
focus on big animals but it's so nice to
sometimes just spend time with little
guys like this they're the cutest little
things and they always up to something
so there's lots of antics to watch and I
thoroughly enjoy actually spending time
with Dorf Mongoose here comes another
one and if that one's going to get
pounced on I also love how everything's
at a million miles an hour and not just
you know you think that they were some
of them would walk down the road but to
know you can't walk down the road you
one must run at full speed in order to
get a good training out of this and I
believe a lot of you are loving this I I
think it's very good one of the better
to off Mongoose ID things I've had in a
long long time I wonder if it's cause
researcher for so long we really move in
here for a long time we've been maybe 15
minutes
so-sorry faith if you can repeat that
again I didn't catch it
Rosalind yes they do look like weasels a
little bit don't they
very small version of a weasel but
they've got that a similar shape and and
gait and and bounce to their running
stride as well as similar sort of for me
they seem like they have similar
characters although there's a lot more
of them are you going to come say hello
at one this is very cool I thought they
were all going to run away at one point
but they've all come out now sorry faith
I didn't get that if you can I got the
question I didn't get the name if you
can just repeat it for me it's coming
through very badly this afternoon
I don't know Craig did you hear that
Craig didn't really get it either
Craig's mumbling as well so it's not
sure which one's worse is my earpiece
that sounds like it's being shoved in a
toilet bowl and underwater or if it's
Craig's mumbling I don't know which
one's harder to understand at this stage
but I didn't get the name so I do
apologize but the question is what do
these Mongoose prey on mostly so Dorf
Mongoose will mostly go after oh hello
little guys are you going to stay there
for us let's see if they will you see
them or they'd Craig on top of the mound
so they all prey on mostly small insects
so they'll go after beetles and grubs
and those kind of things or so lizards
they'll go after birds eggs quite
regularly they'll even take the odd
snake as well so reptiles insects eggs
those are pretty much what the door for
Mongoose targets mostly obviously at
this time of the year it's quite
difficult for them they you know don't
have nearly as much food availability as
they do in the summer months but they
still manage to find what they need
they'll probably lap up a few termites
at times digging around through various
types of dung four kinds of grubs and
and little maggots and mites and all
kinds of things that they can eat but
they are busy little animals aren't they
very very cool to see and then light is
just getting perfect knots that late
afternoon golden lights and these little
guys have actually got really beautiful
details on them we often just look at
them and they kind of look brown and
drab but they've got a beautiful eye
color it's almost this sort of brown
honey color that they've got and then
he's very pretty when they sit in a
place where there's a bit of sunlight
you can actually pick up that eye color
and it is really a very pretty little
animal to see so I quite like them in
when they're in good light and very cool
to look at but
here we go Deirdre you say they remind
you of ferrets ferrets weasels Mongoose
they're all kind of very similar in
their structure and I think that's why
we reminded of all of them when we see
these guises because of their long
bodies longish tails and the way that
their face is shaped about that quite
pointy face so it is very similar of
ferret weasel I'm trying to think of the
name of the other one Martin that's it's
a little Martin you get those in Europe
as well a very cool little things too
right so I think we'll leave our dwarf
Mongoose for me to carry on with the day
because they're all bouncing around all
over the show and I think they are a bit
kind of nervous of our vehicle at times
they get into the road and they may run
off very quickly right well we're going
to carry on looking try see if we can
find any sign of ting Ghana or Dundee
while we do that it sends you back
across to Sydney and the ever so
beautiful little chief
I have got Rev asana here and now asana
is talking a daycare I'm not going to
talk loud because I might spoil the
chances asana is on a mission now and
this attacker that animal is not very
far away so I can see your son is just
wasting waiting waiting for the DECA to
come closer and closer so I'm just
waiting to see what is going to happen
here we might see something very
interesting today
Rosalyn I didn't copy the question very
well and yeah where I am I don't want to
make any mistake now because I can see
that anything the latest did I am not
too sure of the the millimeters but they
might be ranging from 7 to 8 millimeters
so there is a deckhand trying to
approach the water tower and this
leopard is just waiting here and I'm
just waiting to see what is going to
happen behind me I even caught a lot of
impalas coming all these animals are not
aware of the presence of asana yet
Paula I have seen leopard swimming I
have seen leopard seaming they can be
able to see him sometimes they even seem
to the other side of the dams when
wanting to catch animals such as
crocodiles they do seem so here now I am
just waiting something might happen
urgency I have got two different animals
on a very close range
so I can see where the Decker is but
this tech tourism - applause enjoy the
data is just on the other side of Tanana
is just that I cannot move at this stage
because I saw that this taker is so very
much inquisitive I don't want the data
to detect the presence of our sauna
so I'm trying I'm trying to see where
the dagger is because the last time I
saw the day car coming it was a Lea and
the data was coming much more I can see
the data now is going is running away
may be detected a car managed to pick up
the presence of this predator there is
the data the data is avoiding this
direction now that is the Dakin asana
was in at is quite a lot of impalas
behind me also heading towards this
direction so it's just that
Kasana is not yet a way about the
presence of impalas here now his main
focus was on taker and not very far away
from him there are some impalas ahead of
Impala coming towards this direction
and they they can be able to take down
the baby kudos and sometimes they even
take down the baby Ellen I saw a baby
Ireland which is the largest antelope
dragged up into the tree by a leopard
before so here where I am I can promise
you they is quite a lot of pray for this
leopard today so the chances are very
much high and I am so very much excited
so it says that the wind direction is is
not only his favor but I will see how
he's gonna manage the situation Ellen I
never saw that happening but if the the
leopard can be able to go for a
dangerous animal such as a crocodile the
chances of going after the hippo they
are very much high they always want to
take chances and on most occasions they
win
so now I will be waiting to see any
development let's now see what Jim is
doing James is doing unguided walk well
I'm walking on guided walk and
attempting to do some guiding as well
funnily enough and I'm just rather
overwhelmed at the stage the
magnificence of the evening it's it just
could not be a greater privilege and
then it is being out here on foot on
today with the warm temperature gentle
northwest winds the great Herbert cause
a walking point out front graces French
Gabonese Air Force pilot on camera and
the end of winter in sight elephants
magic light there really is just very
special indeed to think that this is
what I do to call work this is what work
is for me it's very hard I hope you all
feel a great deal of sympathy now let's
stop and have a look at this tree wait
I'm receiving a question oh no I'm not
just even question anymore this is a
literal tree and unusually for the
little tree this particular one has got
very green leaves normally they're sort
of silvery blue green but this one has
green leaves and you can see that it has
had a bit of a traumatic time from
elephants but that it got through the
worst of it and it is almost certainly
going to become one of the Giants
eventually but it's going to take a good
hundred or so years before it's a proper
giant and then could last another 900 or
so after that that's how long they live
for me remarkably resilient from the
heart of the wood of course the greater
the chance of him surviving elephant
attack I think that's probably why the
woods out here have such hardwoods
MVP I don't know I wouldn't have
imagined so you know those cats walk
along with fairly bare feet they don't
wear shoes very much so there must be
standing on forms all the time you do
sometimes see them trying to pull thorns
out of their feet but now I don't think
it's a major issue for them at all and
they certainly I mean I've never seen a
I've never seen one of those cats trying
to sharpen their claws on an old thorn
but interesting Lee I was watching some
monkeys the other day more accurately I
was chasing them out of my room where
they had got into my incense - must be
fairly sort of I suppose hippie hippie
monkeys or hipster monkeys they like to
have incense around the maybe they have
Buddhist monkeys that's not the point of
the story the point of the story is that
I chased them out of the room and they
jumped onto a competing tree which is
thornless I climbed up the Camry team
tree after them and they then jumped
from the Collegium tree onto a not
fallen tree and just ran along the
branches now I mean that would be
completely impossible for a human being
to do Sebastien's actually shaking his
head and how they don't tear themselves
to pieces on those trees I just don't
know apparently I was reading today in
my book on hormones and stress that
there are certain hormones that are
secreted by the body that will dead in
your pain receptors so if you're
stressed enough you can accept and take
pain far more than you can without that
stress so you you know hormones will
deaden the nerves at your extremities I
don't believe that I stressed the
monkeys to that extent because I've seen
them just sitting and not thorn trees
very happily just walking around in them
so I can't explain that
yes I'm the mental picture that you have
climbing after the monkeys finding it
very funny is is was quite funny because
obviously the monkey realized I was
actually incompetent once I got into the
tree after it and in fact I got stuck
and it took me quite a long time to get
down from where I got up tree going
right outside my window so I climbed up
jumped onto it great terror and thought
I'm gonna catch you and the thing
started laughing basically margarita I
have walked as little as one mile on
bush walk we've walked as many Aires I
think the most I've walked is 12
kilometers I think on one walk we did
almost 12 kilometers which was which is
how many miles 12 K's he's around about
9 miles or so and I guess today today's
walk will probably be about 7 kilometers
or so 7 yeah almost almost 5 miles so
not very far there's a lot of stopping
and starting and looking and
appreciation you know investigating bits
and pieces some chart for that one's the
best and that one will take you out yes
I do what I can together remember when
we stopped earlier for a calcia not a
kasnia for chili a robusta and I said
maybe it was virtually a Gerardi I I'm
convinced now that it was the chili at
robusta you can see the redness on the
twigs here you see this red bark or
reddish twinge to the bark don't really
see it there can yeah a little bit
and the bark just looked a little
different from this so I'm going to say
that that's what we had there but I
could be wrong gorgeous well the last
trees would have any ants on him and
they'll maintain them of course
throughout the winter let's go back
across the Tristan no idea where he is
no idea what he's doing
no idea what he's going to
I will tell you well James it's a secret
I can't tell what I'm doing no I'm just
driving James I'm doing what what I've
been doing for a vast majority of the
afternoon because he told me that I was
being lazy and sitting in one place and
not doing any work so now I'm driving on
my head because you've been creeping on
me from a dizzy height for not looking
for animals so that's what I'm doing now
I'm just driving around now trying to
find any sign of anything really I
actually had quite a nice afternoon I
thoroughly enjoyed my social animals
that I found this afternoon in the form
of Ellie's and little dwarf Mongoose
they were quite amusing and anything
that comes will be quite nice let's
actually go to puffles look down that's
where we're gonna go and we're gonna go
see if Scuba Steve and snorkel Sarah are
back I wonder what snorkel Sarah's done
with Scuba Steve maybe Scuba Steve has
been has been told that he had to he had
to invest in some new property because
it was beneath snorkel Sarah to be
living inside were full of Dan no view
in buffers exam unfortunately it's too
depressed in the bowl so smoke all Sara
doesn't like she likes a view she likes
a bit of razzmatazz and so she I think
snorkel Sarah probably would be quite
happy at chitwa where she can gaze upon
the big lights of the chitwa city and
you know have a view of the hill with
all the animals before sook dam is just
you know it's too enclosed she feels
claustrophobic here and that's maybe why
Scuba Steve has had to up and leave his
favorite haunts
so I believe a lot of you are quite
entertained by scuba Steve and snorkel
Sara and well it's all James Hindry
really that's created snorkel Sarah and
scuba Steve he was the one that brought
them to life and has given them these
personas and so I wonder I hope that he
comes back because Scuba Steve is is
quite the man is you know as dull as as
dull can be in as about as boring as any
hippo ever was but he's in great itself
into our hearts and lives and and I
think James is quite sad actually that
scuba Steve is no longer a part of the
before swoop dam experience and you know
the before suck dam experience can be
one that is very quiet very regularly
and so you know it was nice to have that
boring hippo sitting doing well nothing
when you came here it was at least
something to look at unlike this
afternoon where there is a simply vast
expanse of water and dust and vegetation
and very little else happening it's not
even really any birds around is there no
I was hoping there might even be a heron
but alas no heron know anything really
no Terrapins oh well it's okay the force
of dam was going to be quiet now I'm
gonna try and see if I can see anything
around this eastern area so all I do
that it sounds like Sidney well he's not
struggling at his dam like I am and he's
got something that she's drinking some
water
I have got the impalas here with me they
are drinking some water and hisana is
just here he's hiding somewhere
Hasan is just here hiding somewhere to
try and catch one of this Impala see
somewhere camouflaged in those classes
so here I am I am very close to any
action which can take place at any time
this is getting very much exciting I
just want to see what was on is going to
do because I saw is hiding not very far
away from where this impalas are so
where I am now I can be able to see both
you can see these impalas they don't
seem very much free they are just
checking everywhere
so I don't want to make any noise here
I'm just gonna be alright for now
so that we can all see what is going to
happen if anything happens
Grateful Dead
that is true
it's just that I cannot talk right now
because I can see otherwise I'm gonna
spoil everything
I can see that these animals are picking
up my voice and they are becoming very
worried because this leopard is just
right next to the dam so every time when
they pick up my voice they concentrate
on me so now I can see that Nara is
heading towards the other side of the
dam this part is not very far away from
where we are is very much close as I'm
just gonna show you now is some way in
this class is right here right there
that black dot in the middle of the
class is a leopard
so I'm not too sure what the leopard is
thinking now but I saw that he was
stalking these animals
so the distance between this leopard and
Tatiana is approximately less than 70
meters is not very far
so all the impalas are done drinking now
this niala is part of the impala head
I'm not too sure what this ayah is
trying to do
maybe he wants to feed today or to do
something
Jonathan that is very true this yes you
can see they are moving every time it
seems like this Mira is very much
suspicious
I'm not sure if maybe Daniela is trying
to pick up my voice as well as the
Predators voice the Predators noise at
the same time
this jnana went past the water hole I
just want to see what Daniela is looking
for here just trying to sniff something
Angelina it is not that very much deep
anything can just happen here this world
has not that very deep the asana can be
able to survive this water is not deep
at all so it no son has just very much
blows to the mill at the moment so I can
see is true they're moving the ears
every time so the Nara did not even
drink but to me the Nara he was looking
very much suspicious
they can see hosannas just they're not
clear at all
so all the impalas and Daniela's they
are done drinking maybe now he's gonna
stalk them I can see that he is trying
to raise up the head to see what's
happening
you can see now the movement is
different he's a way that they are now
away from the dam avaran that is true
Daniela survived this jnana did not even
drink any water here to me 10 Yara was
trying to investigate something so the
only chance for tadhana
to get hold of that impala head is to
follow them
Dixon you are very right because Daniel
went closer to the dead tree and sniffed
the ground but apart from that that Jana
was suspicious from the beginning and
here is where wasana was just walking
around earlier
Betina I can agree with you on that
yes asana has been here for a while in
the area but today before us
it didn't go and lie down there but you
know the cats can always leave behind
their scent because their scent marks it
stays there for quite a long time so
these animals they know they can be able
to detect the cats very easily
so I'm just wanna sit here and see what
is going to be the next step for a son
to do after missing that chance I think
what confused
hosana is that there were four impalas
at the beginning which went towards the
direction where he went for hiding penny
left the water all through there and
when the other ones comes it was already
far and he did not want them to see that
he's there he made a mistake by
following before which came first
so you can see now that in Paris they
are now moving towards that direction
so these impalas it was very difficult
for them to smell the cat but let me
tell you something the wind direction
was coming from where the lion they the
leopard was nigh but it did not tear the
impalas anything about the presence of
Hosanna
the wind was always blowing from Isana
truth in Paris but still that didn't
help the impalas to detect or sir
so while I'm waiting here James has got
a beautiful sunset let's see the sunset
from James sunset is magnificent
over here as you can see it's gone down
a Sun has set another week out here now
many people think of Sunday as the first
to ever Lee obviously ridiculous
I just wanted also to say of course that
while yes maybe there's niala smell to
asana I'm of the opinion of course of
these cats clean themselves precisely so
that they are not smelt and if I mean
we've had those cats so close to us
lions and leopards and you can't smell
them and they walk past obviously
antelope have got more sensitive noses
than ours
but if you compare them with a hyena or
a wild dog which really hadn't quite
phenomenally they really don't compare
and something else I wanted to say out
on the site on the subject of smell I
thought I'd just go through the smells
of this evening because it's been so
warm there's obviously a lot more smelly
thing in the air I guess at normally
when it's cold we don't have quite the
same smells and there's a lot of sort of
straw sweet straw all from this dry
grass a little bit of what will we
describe it as let's say I don't really
describe this potpourri there's a very
mild sort of spice sent from the
competing leaves you can keep them out
of those and then there's that scent of
African dust which I think many people
would understand if they've been out
here certainly when I was trying to
describe the other day saved from behind
the camera said it smelled South Africa
not quite that accent but uh you'll get
my drift so that's what it smells off to
us
all righty we're heading bound towards
where husana is we're obviously going to
try and avoid him we don't want to freak
him out but we're on our way home with
the sunset we don't want to be out at
night and this is another good time for
me to say to you of course we refer to
horse Anna in the most friendly terms we
refer to him as our sweet little chief
our favorite cutely cutie pie leopard
whatever it is it's now after the Sun
has gone down once it's dark that you
really would not want to meet asana
on foot you know he's a wild leopard and
we must always just remember that must
lose our connection to his wildness
because he's a he's a wild fellow wild
crazy good see if we can't find you one
or two more things before we disappear
off air for good look what happened here
let's try and uncover forensically what
occurred in this region I think this was
in part everybody a whole lot of Impala
around here and for obviously having a
bit of a lie down now you know it is not
in parlance it's warthogs it's warthogs
digging and having a sort of a bath if
you like and then also there have been
Impala that have been marking territory
it's very interesting that they're quite
a big hole Paula um in terms of smell
perfume doesn't matter human beings
stink of human being and animals know
that smell perfume if anything would
disguise your human scent and they may
smell it not register that it is a
threat so you know if I know we like to
think of ourselves once we've got out of
the shower as being smell free but to
let me assure you to any animal we
absolutely hum of human being and it's
not a smell than anything not yet
appreciates at all if you really want it
just guys you'll smell out here Paula
when you arrive find a couple of fresh
buffalo patties line them up and roll in
those
and then you will smell like the bush
and you will be able to approach animals
much more closely than we were able to
today I have yet to accept that I need
to make the social sacrifice out here so
I'm not going to roll myself in any fish
Buffalo down if it's all the same to you
alrighty let's have a last look over
here I can just see my own beginnings of
the new growth of the strictness
Madagascar incest plant now the
strictness Madagascar incest Fronda in
my hand was chopped by human being you
know attempt to Bush care this area so
they were chopped out because they were
so thick e'er that they were making it
difficult for animals to move through
the area and we're just getting thicker
and thicker you can see that it has had
no effect on the actual life of the
plant and all it's done is make the base
that much thicker and that's a bit
distressing because it does mean of
course that this plant is going to grow
back thicker and stronger it's a bit
like pruning I suppose say if you really
want to cure an area of trees like this
you've got to come and pull them up by
the roots or poison them and obviously
you don't want to be put poisoning don't
want to be putting poisoned or in the
world area like this because who knows
what other effects it will have so
interesting that and I think probably
largely a function people say there's
too many elephants in this area we need
to get rid of some they're destroying
the trees much better idea for the
elephants to come and do this job for
you there on a regular basis I don't
think there are too many elephants here
at all alrighty
Tristan still looking for Qing Ghana as
the Sun Goes Down we will bid you adieu
from the before
well I am but I once or no from James
before he goes anywhere so faith you
need to ask him this did he walk on
central to start his bush walk this
afternoon because if he did on my
right-hand side yeah is a track now I'm
going to try lean out of the way but
there should be I'm trying to see where
it is exactly this this here is a
footprint for what looks like James it
looks like a size seven which would be
about James's size so it's facing the
hill is at the back away from me and in
the toe coming forward but just off to
the right you'll notice that there is a
leopard track that is on top of that
said footprint and the track of what
looks like King Ghana's so if James
walked out this afternoon then ting
Ghana has walked on top of his track
during the course of the afternoon but
I'm not sure that is exactly James's
track and whether or not they did walk
here during the course of today
interesting but it does cut off here
because out of northwards into this
block towards Gauri cut line area so I'm
going to just have a little look around
it actually comes back again so it's
back on the road walking still in a
westerly direction this must beat in
Ghana where he's gone I'm not quite sure
I'll just double check and see faith in
any word from James whether he walked on
Central this afternoon
[Music]
so James has already turned off his
radio therefore we can't find out if he
is the one that's walked on Central this
afternoon okay well let's try this I
mean we never know I drove here just now
and didn't notice that the tracks were
on top of the footprints I saw the
footprints but I didn't notice
Tinh Garner's tracks on top I saw his
tracks coming off of the Ala it's south
but I thought they might have been from
this morning because Reax told me he had
tracks routes in Ghana this morning but
like I say these tracks for whoever
walked here look as though they are from
this afternoon I suppose it could be
this morning's bushwalk tracks he was on
Bush walk this morning reg do you know
no Craig was also not working this
morning can't remember
kate's well no because if he was
stalking /tracking James he's
unfortunately walking in the complete
opposite direction to the footprints
that were going so James as well
whoever's footprints were going that way
and this lipid is going this way so it
would be the opposite direction I'm
afraid and therefore it would be a very
poor effort from Tigana if he was
tracking James more likely that he's
moving about in this area tracking
husana or tündi they mean anything else
so there is off for both of them because
obviously Masana is epiderm and Tandy is
on the eastern side quite far away from
this area under the waiting ghana ended
up in which way his tracks went maybe
they went into this block yeah and he's
just been sleeping in the block it might
be a good idea just to go and check
around the big jackal berry sometimes
comes out of that area and we might get
lucky in fact that's where he came out
the other morning with Columba that's
where he appeared out of nowhere so I
wonder if he's made me done a repeat
performance of that
and see any more tracks on the road so I
think he must have gone into the block
and maybe cuts northwards
here's the big jackal baby on my
right-hand side so I'll go check their
creepy thing about taganas this is a
good time for him now we're at a time
where he's will start waking up and
start moving and I'm hoping he'll call
because if he calls well be very easy to
find him then if given we're in the
proximity to actually hear him calling
but let's just have a little scan from
this jackal berry tree there's a little
track that goes this way that I can just
stop at and we can have a little scan on
this drainage line to see if I can see
anything nothing at the jackal bury
itself but I can see no let's have a
look let's go down and have a little
quick squeeze down here this is often a
good place for our leopards so we often
do find lipids that are moving about in
these areas they like it's in this
drainage line even though it's so big
and open in this section we just go
slightly north of yet becomes closed and
small and the perfect place for a
leopard to spend his day or her day
resting so we know Tandy and Colombo use
this quite regularly and Tenggara as
well seen husana here seen Tambor here
so it's a good place for a number of our
lipids
straw head the dry terrain by far is
much easier to track animals in and it
becomes dusty it becomes soft soil and
this is far less vegetation and so
tracking is 99 percent fact 100 percent
easier then it would be in the wind in
the wet season the wet season is can be
very difficult to track particularly if
the tracks are before the rain and then
obviously you don't see them at all so
dry season is great for tracking now is
the best time ever to track animals as
we start to go into August September it
really does get absolutely the easiest
that you can ask for and that's why
everybody loves this time of year for
tracking in summer really test your
skill a lot more than it does in the
winter months
no sign of tengan I'm afraid I was just
hoping by off chance he was sleeping
somewhere here and I could pick up his
tracks but I don't see any sign of him
anywhere here so I'll keep looking and
keep scratching her I know I just stop
and turn off for a while and listen
while I do that though
Sydnee who has no such problem with
trying to find his animal is filled with
a straw sauna and I wonder what Hasan is
going to be up to next
oh so nice now after the day girl
you can see asana in the day girl they
are not that very far apart is looking
right at that a girl
so the day care unexpectedly approach to
asana and the time was are not
discovered the day care is there it was
late
then the day care became suspicious and
decided to move towards that direction
they can see that was Anna today is
really on hunting mood this is looking
at the taker and something else I am not
too sure what oh son is trying to do
because he's concentrating on the taker
and is also something that is changing
on the other side maybe is something
that I cannot see from where I am now he
is looking at that side and he is also
looking at a daycare on the other side
so the day have decided to disappear but
his focus is still day
James they the cats are very much
interesting and they normally catch just
by this time when his duck is well this
enough cover for them to hide I can see
that taker is also still on the other
side look at the daycare now from the
other side of the of the dry riverbed
you see the taker is moving and was
honest looking at the tiger so you can
see that it's not that very far away
where this data is from us and look at
him there and it's just looking at the
taker
again normally they catch they come they
approach and when they are at about less
than 40 meters is when they start
running but animal status or come off
leash such as the leopards they don't
run such long distances because animals
can come too close and they catch so
this was the spots on the leopard helps
them to reduce the distance when it
comes to the prey prey always come very
much closer than them so you can see
that he is looking after something the
ears are moving very slowly and is not
moving at all the body is not moving at
all
this is amazing
so this is very much beautiful you can
see now look at the tear reflection of
the sunset nice and pink so you can see
is it is about to get dark now maybe is
when he will take a decision to go after
something
so lady stuff a yes Kasana is a
beautiful cat I I do enjoy asana
sightings I always want to spend much
time with our sauna
so at this stage I can see that Osama
just decided to go disappear so I'm
gonna try by all means and find him
again
joy and the I didn't copy that call what
I heared it was just the Franklin's I
didn't manage to pick up that call so
I'm just gonna try and reallocate or
sauna so I'll be moving to the other
side of the dry riverbed maybe from the
other side we might get better visuals
so husana just got disturbed and then
decided to go up to the other side I
don't know what exactly irritated him
so I'll be heading towards the other
side of the dry riverbed but let's go to
Tristan
maybe Tristan has got something
interesting at the moment
unfortunately not Sydney my afternoon
has petered out a little bit after
starting so nicely it's what's a little
on the quiet side and haven't found too
much more it's obviously too dark now to
do any intense tracking of ting ganas if
we'd spotted his tracks earlier we might
have but it's now a little bit too dark
and I sat for a bit son Gary cutline
listen didn't hear any sign of him
moving no alarm calls no vocalizing no
anything and so I hear that he is still
asleep wherever he may be maybe he had a
long day of walking so no sign of him
yet so we're still just going to try and
stay in the area in case he does
vocalize or something like that's what
pops out on one of these roads as we
were saying earlier it's the perfect
time for him to start waking up but
there's this beautiful pink light that
is kind of coming out at the moment
we're getting this beautiful pinkish
color in the sky which is very pretty as
we go under a whole bunch of knob thorns
that are looking very wintry now what's
interesting is actually the only thought
about this today is that we're in July
now it is the 29th of July yes
so knob phone's as far as I know have
not flowered yet and I was thinking
about it today that they often do flower
in mid July towards end of July and so
would have been nice to have seen them
start flowering I know Steph said he had
some knob fronds flowering at his home
in Hood spray which is just north of
here not very far so I wonder if ours
are going to start flowering very
shortly it would be nice to see some
flowering knob phones again they're
always so pretty when they come out and
add a bit of color to our drab winter
although they're not exactly a bright
color are they they're kind of creamy
color
look very much like a lot of the grass
or aren't you but they add a lot of life
to the knob thorns a lot of things go to
them like birds and the likes
NASA too late I actually don't know to
be honest with you I don't know what the
oldest living tree is in South Africa or
where it is to be honest Craig you know
no Craig doesn't know either I honestly
have no idea there's an interesting
question though I feel like I should
know it's a now I feel very bad that I
don't oh well I'll have to go and
research it and get back to you but I
honestly don't know what our oldest
living tree is to be honest in South
Africa be nice to find out exactly where
I'll try and have a little research
quickly and see what I can find I would
imagine it might be a bear bag or maybe
a big yellow word down in the knives and
a forests I'll have a little look
quickly and see if I can find any
information I love about it while I do
that listen you across the Sydney who
maybe knows something that I don't
I have got ting honor now and your
effort Osama and husana is now hunting I
can see that Osama is after I take a
look and see how he's standing there
they say Decker not very far away from
where he's at the moment so just couple
of meters away so I just want to see his
approach direction I think he lost the
daiquiri
a right way is going is where the taker
is
so you can see how he's concentrating
so this is beautiful ray
so the oldest living tree in South
Africa that is quite a very difficult
question to answer
I am not sure which species that however
I will suggest that the the fig trees
can also they can also grow very old
yes we've also got the lead woods which
can go for thousands of years and the
bio Bop so is difficult to bear to tear
not to show but I will investigate
getting back to hunting ting Ghana is
right now on a hunt in Astana is right
now only hundred so and I'm gonna pull
forward just I'm gonna pull forward now
so that we can have a better visual
so is it is very much difficult to see
where is I can see him now but his come
of late way is heading towards the prey
he's trying to recover all the
opportunities he lost while he was by
the dam
first is somewhere hiding here slowly
approaching you can see is just in
between the bushes
there's quite a lot of pearl spotted our
Colleen
so it seems like these quite a lot of
daycares here because where I am I can
see the second data as well going up so
he might be successful and get a meal
tonight
so it is quite very difficult to see
they play at this stage but I saw the
data went somewhere between those trees
just behind those trees
[Music]
I can't even see where the Kasana is
hiding now but he's hiding somewhere not
very far away from where I am
by this time of the night
this kind of cats can be very much
conflict I was hoping to see a killer
this afternoon it was very interesting
seeing this beautiful cat attempting to
hunt
so I just want to try by all means and
reallocate his position because I can't
see him at all here so it's just
somewhere behind this termite mound
between the termite world and this thick
bushes there so I'm just gonna pull
forward and see if I can have a
now and I am going to be looking for
this leopard again
let's see Tristan has got an answer with
regards to the biggest tree in South
Africa they always tree in South Africa
indeed I Do's I did research quickly and
I believe the oldest tree in South
Africa is well I said two different
trees I said baobab and yellow it which
was my guess as to what the oldest trees
would be and by a country mile
it is a babe AB apparently now I'm not
100% sure if this is verified but there
is a bear babe in gravel Lots which is
not actually that far from here it's
north of Hood sprites so between here
and Pella boil which is a an entry gates
into the kruger national park if you
want to look on a map there's a place
called gravel lots and gravel lots has
got some a about minutes that they
reckon is about 2000 years old give or
take five hundred years because of
course you can't be too close and and
500 years is not a lot apparently I
don't know you feel like they could get
closer then give or take 500 and that's
there's a big difference between 1500
and 2500 but anyway that's what they
reckon is this 2000 year old tree and
then there is behind that a yellow woods
so
a I think it's a boots large or
something lifts yellowwood I can't
remember exactly which one it is
but the yellow wood is second in a mere
six hundred years old give or take ten
years so I feel like there's a massive
discrepancy here and I want to know why
because how is it that they can get a
six hundred years tree and they get ten
years and then a two thousand year tree
there's a difference of five hundred
potentially it doesn't seem right in my
mind I feel like I'm being lied to in
some way and I don't know how to figure
it out but anyway that's the idea
apparently that's roughly the the
figures and whether or not that is 100%
accurate so I'm not quite sure it was a
brief little search that I did just to
try and have a little look quickly but
they say that that's where they are so I
was it would imagine both of those were
the trees that were going to be oldest
and the yellow wood is funny enough the
widest tree that has been measured in
South Africa there was a yellow world
that was measured at seven meters in
girth which is absolutely monstrous and
second place went to the bear bear which
was I think just over six or just around
six meters in girth which is obviously a
very big tree I mean you'd be able to
almost live inside something like that
so quite interesting and amazing trees
that we've got we've got some really
really beautiful trees unfortunately I
think as is the world over a lot of the
most iconic and biggest trees have been
lost in many areas due to deforestation
and just general abuse of our tree
environment it's not ideal that's in
many parts of the world and it's not
only South Africa that large tracts of
indigenous push that contrary that
contain really beautiful specimens of
trees have been destroyed I you just
have to look at places like Borneo where
palm oil plantations have destroyed
massive areas the Amazon rainforest
congo rain by Congo Basin lots of big
trees being cut down all over the place
which is a shame in a way you know you
there's something about a massive tree
that evokes some sort of hope and some
sort of wonder in you and even as a kids
you know you take a kid to go and see a
massive tree and you can see that their
mind kind of works over time as they
sort of wander up and look with these
big eyes at this massive tree that's hey
if we didn't have those mess of iconic
trees like that spread across the world
that could inspire you know all kinds of
people to take an interest in the
natural world and particularly you know
the tree world I'm not a very big tree
person but obviously a lot of the
so never too late you say seeing the
oldest tree in South Africa is now on
your bucket list well it is isn't it I
was also thinking the exact same thing
just now thought it would be quite nice
to try and go and hunt down the biggest
tree I wonder if it's on a place where
you can actually go see it or if it's in
a on a private farm somewhere or what
the situation is with it I don't know
maybe we can find somebody that knows
whether or not we can go and see the
oldest tree in South Africa be cool if
you could generally those big bayer babs
are actually open to the public and
especially if they have something like
that I would imagine that there will be
somebody that all be alarmed what some
way of getting to go and see it
okay well we're still looking around
fitting ah I can't pass Galago pan in
the hope that he might be here sorry
little folktale drummer but no sign of
him
so we'll keep having a little scratch
around while we do that to send you back
across to Sydney with they're still
hunting hasanah
hosana is still a much hunting year
where I am now I can see still his
concentration is on something not to
show if the data are very much close to
him because it's getting very dark which
is making it very difficult for me to
see but now you can see you can see that
it's moving now so this case can be very
much camouflaged
so I'm just gonna try and pull forward
so that we can have a better sighting
because I can see now he is trying to go
that way
not too sure if he's trying to avoid us
or his intention is after something on
that side so let me try and read the
situation and see what is planning to do
at this stage
you know I can see where a Sunday flea
camera
you can see there that is just in the
middle of this bushes very much
difficult to see it on a more camera
that look by the flee camera is very
very much clear so this this evening
Kasana is not even interested on marking
any territory all he's doing is going
after they the daycares and the impalas
so he is very hungry at the moment
so you can see now he is not
concentrating on the play anymore is
just walking away now to show if he gave
up
they see listening again hasanat us
trust his ears a lot
our beer thank you very much for the
command years by the FLIR
hosana is very much nice and clear look
at that you can even see this tail
moving so it has been very much stunning
following our sauna
[Laughter]
Bobby I haven't seen any other leopard
with such a beautiful personality
hosana is my first one and I am really
starting to fall in love with asana is
quite a very beautiful young male with a
very beautiful nice pink nose so this
asana is now becoming my favorite yes I
laughed in Ghana a lot but asana is
getting there and how it does things is
amazing nice and clever young leopard so
I'm just going to now drive and see I'm
going to go further and see if we can
have a another chance with a beautiful
cat so hosana challenged my voice this
afternoon as I had to whisper all the
way from the dam until here we are
because I didn't want to disturb I could
see that the prey the prey were
concentrating on me and also asana was
concentrating on me which was very much
difficult for me to communicate nicely
with you
there is he nice and beautiful
it has been a lovely afternoon spending
much of the day with husana it has been
very much amazing and thank you very
very much for all your comments and
questions let's meet again tomorrow at
half past six